the terrorist attack at the Manchester
Arena was a terrible tragedy
the bomber killed 22 innocent people and
harmed many others
my thoughts are with the families and
friends of those killed
and with all those whose lives were
changed by this appalling Act of
terrorism
having examined all the evidence the
chair of the inquiry has found that
there was a realistic possibility
that actionable intelligence could have
been obtained
which might have led to actions
preventing the attack
I deeply regret that such intelligence
was not obtained
Gathering covert intelligence is
difficult
but had we managed to seize the slim
chance we had
those impacted might not have
experienced such appalling loss and
Trauma
I am profoundly sorry
that MI5 did not prevent the attack
the people of MI5 and our policing
Partners come to work every day to stop
terrorism
we continually work to improve the
counter-terrorism system
since the terrible events of 2017
we have made more than a hundred
improvements
but we are determined to do more
as the chair and I considers his
recommendations we will engage freely
where there are opportunities to
strengthen the UK's defenses further
MI5 will act
we will continue to do everything in our
power to keep our country safe from
hidden threats
MI5 exists to stop atrocities
to all those whose lives were forever
changed on that awful night
I am so sorry that MI5 did not prevent
the attack at the Manchester Arena